I'm Megan heights I'm a senior data
scientist on the data products team at
Rent the Runway and today we're going to
be talking about senpai a discrete event
simulation Python and how I used it to
launch our newest warehouse in June of
this year the reason I wanted to give
this talk is I think a lot about what
our data science toolkit is and often I
think about it as statistics and
hypothesis testing in a regression and
machine learning may be maybe a
reinforcement learning may be neural
networks and NLP but when we were
starting to think about launching this
new warehouse I realized that none of
these tools were really going to help
solve this problem for us deep learning
and machine learning are really great
for solving problems when you have a ton
of data but you're trying to understand
like what the process is so your data is
gonna help you like learn what your
model should be we were kind of in the
opposite situation where we understood
our process perfectly because our
engineers had built our fulfillment
system but we had zero observations
because we had not opened our warehouse
yet so that led us to like building out
a simulation and as the data scientist I
didn't really have like a ton of
experience in building simulations and I
didn't really know a lot of other people
that built a lot of them before and
that's kind of like how we got
introduced to senpai and you know maybe
that resonates with you and maybe there
are things that you can do at your own
company with simulations that you hadn't
thought about before
so today we're gonna talk about what
Rent the Runway is we have like a pretty
unique business model and I would say
the the first thing you need to know
when you're building a simulation is
kind of have a conceptual model in your
mind of what you're building we'll talk
about why business like ours would need
a simulation engine in order to launch
the warehouse again another really
important thing is when you're building
a simulation you're gonna have to kind
of understand what questions you're
trying to answer before you start
building it in order to understand like
what level of granularity you need to
really focus on then we'll talk about
discrete event simulation what you might
use it for or not use it for and maybe
some examples of things you could do at
your own
with it we'll do a couple of toys ampuls
and senpai and then we'll talk about how
we used our senpai simulation tool in
order to watch our warehouse one little
aside they're going to start with which
is a little uncomfortable for us is last
month we had a bunch of warehouse issues
and I will just say that a discrete
event simulation is really good for
understanding your risk profile for like
what will happen if you have a bug in
your system but it will not help you it
will not prevent you from like or it
will not predict your like issues it
will be something you're really really
happy to have if there's like a
catastrophic failure in your operations
and you have to come up with a new plan
very very quickly so this is a an image
from our warehouse in the middle of the
bug and this is what it looks like now
so everything is back to normal and
functioning well so kind of back to the
main topic at hand
what is Rent the Runway maybe the women
in this audience know what we do but I
would imagine many of you don't we've
been around for about 10 years and we
started out doing rentals of expensive
designer dresses primarily for one-time
events so this would be like you are
bridesmaid in your best friend's wedding
and she wants you to buy a $10,000 you
know $1,000 dress and you're like that
is not something I really want to do and
you say hey can I maybe rent this from
Rent the Runway instead so we call this
our reserve business and primarily
people are doing rentals for special
events like a gala or a New Year's Eve
party or prom or wedding and people are
paying for rental they're scheduling
this in advance and then we have a
predetermined return date but they're
sending it back to us now in the last
two years our business has evolved and
changed a lot so many of you may
remember when Netflix was not a
streaming service but you got sent a DVD
in this little nitpick slip so like it
comes to you maybe you don't get around
till watching it until next Tuesday then
you finish it up and you send it back
and Netflix sends you a new DVD we're
essentially doing the same thing but
with clothes
so our customers are paying a monthly
subscription fee they get four slots for
different pieces of clothing and instead
of it just being for special events
people are renting for work wear or date
or just casual stuff or maybe they are
like renting for a wedding and people
can just order whatever is currently in
the warehouse we ship it out to them
that day and then they can keep it for
however long they want so they could
send it back the same day they could
send it back a month later and we're
promising them a two-day shipping time
turnaround both to and from so this is
kind of like what it looks like on our
website this is what I had rented out
last week just like a fall coat and a
sweater because getting cold obviously
Christian Siriano dress for a wedding I
went to and then just like a little
cocktail dress I wore on a date with my
husband you can probably gather that
these two businesses have very different
operations first of all our reservations
are not made for in advance all of our
reservations come in on the same day we
can't ship things out early for cheaper
shipping costs so like if you are
renting a wedding dress and we knew we
had to get it to you in on December
something we could ship it out early to
make sure to make sure it got to you but
for our subscription we've got to send
it up by air if you're outside of our to
date ground shipping zone we also have
no known return date so we don't really
know when these pieces of clothing are
going to come back to us so in a
nutshell like forecasting on a SKU level
basis for a reserved business it's like
relatively hard but forecasting for the
unlimited business is extremely
difficult but we're kind of willing to
deal with that complexity because this
business is growing a lot it's now the
vast majority of our business people
seem to really like it they don't turn
very much from it and really happy with
it but this obviously presents what I
would like to call a happy problem for
our company we had one warehouse in New
Jersey but this dramatically growing
customer base all across the country and
the map that we're looking at here is
UPS ground shipping zones so from our
New Jersey warehouse so everyone in the
yellow and the brown is in the one and
two-day shipping zone so we can like
meet our customer promise to them just
shipping out in trucks
and everyone else in like green red and
orange we had to ship out by air so that
means the shipping costs are a little
more expensive for us but like we have a
bigger problem which is they were just
complete like completely at capacity so
we have a ton of demand for this
business but there's no way for us to
ship out all those shipments from this
one warehouse so naturally what we're
gonna do is we're gonna build a second
warehouse and we decided to build the
second warehouse in Texas so we are
theoretically we are expanding our scale
so we can have more shipments we're
gonna have faster returns and delivery
for our customers and we're supposed to
be able to reduce our transportation
costs so you might be wondering why do
you need to simulate that it doesn't
seem that complicated to build a second
warehouse well our business is fairly
unique we're different from other retail
and e-commerce companies because we're
renting out our clothing and not just
selling it to people it happens that our
customers are actually holding most
urban inventory at any one point in time
so I can't really go to warehouse one
and just fill up a truck and bring it to
my second warehouse I have to accumulate
imagery in that warehouse through
returns
so the second warehouse is actually
going to start out mostly empty so we
have to understand how quickly we can
ramp the second warehouse up through
inventory accumulation so I'm gonna send
out to a customer in Des Moines from my
New Jersey warehouse this dress and then
she's gonna have a Texas return label
and send it back to the new Texas
warehouse but I don't want that
inventory to be sitting around idle in
Texas so people are still gonna have the
opportunity to order that so we've got
customer orders coming in and customers
leaving and we need to understand how
quickly we can fill up this leaky bucket
and that's important to us because what
we want to do is we want to ramp this
second warehouse and then map each of
our customers to a single warehouse so
customers will only be able to see the
Texas warehouse or they'll only be able
to see the New Jersey warehouse another
thing that we need to know is like how
expensive this is going to be for our
shipping during this ramp up process say
I'm a customer in Auckland and I order
this leather jacket and this floral
cocktail dress
if I only have that leather jacket in
stock in New Jersey and that floral
cocktail dress in stock in Texas then
I'm gonna have to double my shipping
costs and send out two separate
shipments to her this obviously is like
a pretty big financial impact for us but
there's kind of a secondary effect to
this too where if people have two
different return bags with them they can
speed up their swap rates so not only is
that shipment more expensive but the
customer becomes more expensive in
general so that's kind of like where we
realized that we really needed to build
a discrete event simulation order so
discrete event simulation needs to
primarily be two things
it must be dynamic so your state
variables are changing over time and it
must be discrete so you have significant
changes happening in your system at
individual time instances the nice thing
is that it can be deterministic or
stochastic deterministic being
everything in your system is entirely
predictable or stochastic being you have
some type of randomness in your system
so you might be wondering like what can
you actually use discrete amid
simulators for say you're working for
SpaceX or NASA and you need to simulate
rocket trajectory this is not something
you're gonna use discrete event
simulators for because you're gonna
require a continuous simulation for that
additionally there's really no discrete
changes your that are happening in your
system except for takeoff when it comes
to dice roll outcomes theoretically you
could use a discrete event simulation
this system but it would kind of be
overkill because it's not dynamic if
you're playing craps at 3 a.m. versus 10
a.m. your outcomes are not really
changing based on like where you are in
that space so instead you would probably
focus on building something like a Monte
Carlo simulation for this a thing that
people definitely use des is for is
understanding how long it takes to work
clean so all the major airlines have
like employed people to work on figuring
out what's the best way for them to
board and I guess there's one
astrophysicist who has come up with like
the most efficient way to do that
and he says that you should board on
either aisle from the window seats in
however because you want to have as many
people putting their bag above above as
you can in parallel obviously no one
actually does this because it's too
difficult to get people to follow this
process this is a system that's dynamic
because seats are filling up over time
it's discrete because each of these
customers is getting on the plane and
taking a seat and it's stochastic
because people do random things so maybe
you think you might want to do some type
of discrete event simulation at your own
company there's like a couple of
examples of how other people use them
the classic des example is modeling a
cue system for customer service so
understanding how many agents do you
need to process all the calls coming in
without people reneging or leaving your
line because it's taking too long things
like designing lines at a supermarket
you might recognize this as the Union
Square queue at Whole Foods I would bet
my firstborn child that amazon designed
a DES before they put this in the Whole
Foods and then another thing might be
like simulating car sham pickup so why
are we using discrete event simulation
system well we know it's dynamic because
the second warehouse is changing over
time as our imagery accumulates we know
it's discrete because each customer
order is changing this data our network
once they order something I can't
fulfill it for someone else and we can
model it either deterministically using
our historical orders before the
warehouse opened or stochastically with
probabilistically generated orders so
this is like kind of the output of our
trivial simulation inside in sin pi so
we've got the New Jersey warehouse and
the Texas warehouse in orders are being
sent out from these two warehouses and
we're keeping track of how many of them
are from Texas how many are from New
Jersey we're also keeping track of how
many of them are normal as in you are a
you live in New Jersey I send your order
out from New Jersey versus a cross
shipment whereas you live in New Jersey
but all the stuff you orders is in Texas
and I have to
from Texas and split being I have to
spin it out from both warehouses we used
this kind of trivial simulation because
we could hand calculate out what the
answer should be and we used it as an
exception an acceptance test in our
notes and your in our simulator
development so simpie is just a open
source python-based
MIT licensed package that does discrete
event simulation it's kind of designed
around this idea that you can use Python
generators to simulate active processes
and all that the kind of components that
you're dealing with in that are your
environment which acts as your clock
your processes which you just implement
as regular Python generators your events
which act as futures or promises and
resources which are shared throughout
your simulation and used by processes so
the first kind of toy example we're
gonna do is straight out of the simp I
tutorial we're just gonna simulate this
car process which you're alternately
driving and parking for a while kind of
going over in the loop so what that
looks like is our car is gonna park for
two time periods and then it's gonna
drive for three time periods we can run
this simulation and at any point in time
we know the position of that car the
first thing you're gonna have to do is
select this Empire environment that
you're going to simulate this in there's
two environments just a regular
environment in the real time environment
you're really only gonna use the
real-time environment if you have some
time type of like hardware component
that you're simulating or some type of
human intervention that's necessary so
most of us are probably gonna choose the
regular simple environment and what this
is gonna do is gonna act as your
scheduler and your event loop manager
the next thing you need to understand is
what events you want to simulate in your
process I'll be honest I'm sure there
are people who use simple events much
more effectively than us but we
realistically only used this in PI time
out event and this is the event that's
going to like use you're gonna use to
pass time throughout your simulation so
you're gonna yield after some delay has
passed
you're gonna write out your sim pie
process just a reminder where Park
and then we're driving when we write
this on Python it's just a regular
generator but you pass in your simple
environment as an argument and you yield
using the senpai time at events so we're
just parking for a while we yield a
timeout for that duration and then we
drive for a while and again Gil the
timeout we're gonna make this a little
more complicated and also say that our
car needs to be charged before I can
start driving so we're gonna develop
some simple resources here that resource
is going to be a battery charging
station our process is going to request
that resource and if it is available it
will be yielded and held by our process
until it concludes when the process is
done that resource will be released what
that looks like in Python is just you
pass that into your process you request
the battery charging station bcs if it's
yielded then we can continue on to the
charging process and that's really all
we need to run our first toy example
we're gonna instantiate our senpai
environment we're gonna set up our
battery charging station resource and
then we're gonna set up for car driving
processes and tell her tell Tim PI to
start running our simulation so we're
just hanging out
parked still parking we're gonna start
trying to drive so the first few cars
all the cars right now are requesting
charging but there's only two so only
the first two cars are getting that
resource then they're ready to start
driving that resource is released and
the second set of cars is able to start
charging and then we can just like off
to the races drive to our destination
and that's it so they're like very
simple building blocks to run these like
very simple simulations the next example
is a little like closer to my heart as
an RTR employee so we're gonna be
fulfilling some orders out of our
warehouse and we're making some pretty
drastic simplifying assumptions to make
this a toy example we're gonna assume
that all of our dresses are fungible so
it doesn't matter if you don't like the
dress or it doesn't fit you you're happy
with this dress all of our customers are
keeping their their items for the same
amount of time
and our new orders are being made on a
regular cadence we're gonna set up our
simple resource which is our dresses
we're just gonna give it any number of
dresses and these dresses are gonna be
used up by our order processes and then
release from the order is complete and
we'll write out our set our order
process or order is going to request a
dress from the warehouse and if it's
available the warehouse will send that
dress out and then the it will be held
at home for the time the customers using
the item we're gonna wrap this up in a
setup and set up the 3 different orders
and then we're gonna add another order
at a regular interval and then we're
ready to run our simulation so initially
we're gonna run the simulation with only
one dress we're gonna run it where
people are gonna keep them for two days
every three days we're gonna get a new
order and we're gonna run our system for
eight days and pretty obviously this
like doesn't work out well for us we
have three orders and only one dress so
we have a bunch of fashion emergencies
even at time one time two we're gonna
still not have our dresses and we're
gonna be upset about that three we're
gonna get one dress back in the
warehouse and we're able to send out a
dress for order to order three never
gets their dress and order at time four
we're getting another order in and more
fashion emergencies so we know that this
is never gonna catch up and this is like
not a feasible amount of dresses to have
small aside we work in the same building
as the Olsen twins and they are just as
cute today as they are in this gift so
now we're gonna write our run our
simulation with enough dresses so we're
gonna start out with three dresses
because we have three orders we're gonna
run through that and everything is fine
we have all our orders
we send our dresses they come back to
the warehouse and we're able to see that
our order for our dress for order number
four you might even argue that we have
too many dresses at this point because
technically we have two days to send the
dresses out so like everyone's happy but
we could have been like a little leaner
perhaps obviously it's pretty easy to
know that if you've got three orders
your
I need at least three dresses the system
that we're working with is obviously a
lot more complex than that
we have inventory that's always changing
both like new dresses that were getting
in dresses that are deactivated because
we've rented them out too many times and
they're a little too worn out to keep
printing and then things that people buy
so people have the option to buy the
thing you'll never get back to the
warehouse obviously people are also
keeping these items for drastically
different times you could send something
out and doesn't fit them they send it
back the same day or they could keep it
for months
and then our dresses are not fungible we
have many thousands of different types
of dresses in many different sizes our
demand is not stationary and our
shipping time is going to vary a lot
both by location and method that we use
to ship the item luckily it's really not
that hard to encode all that into a
senpai simulation simpie is not very
opinionated about what your simulation
is going to be so like we could like
really just write out all of the classes
and generators and everything we needed
to do to simulate out what this was
gonna look like for us and that meant
that we could take our historical order
data and different strategies that we
had about watching this warehouse run a
ton of different simulations and then
measure the outcomes of these kind of
like report back to our stakeholders
about how we wanted to do this launch so
this is like part of one day the output
of one of our simulations we can see
like all these like cross shipments and
like normal shipments and like Secaucus
is still like creating tons of shipments
and we can like run this for like
several months and understand kind of
like what this ramped up process is
gonna look like for us and this was
really important for us because we had a
bunch of important decisions to make one
of which was defining which regions had
access to which warehouse over time so
this kind of like mapping decided how we
assigned return labels for the dresses
and how we assigned like priority depots
for the reservations and we would change
these maps over time because this is our
major lever for controlling how our
inventory accumulates not just like how
much but what is accumulating
these regions have like very different
populations which I can tell you
correlates with the number of
subscribers there they also have very
different style preferences but also
different weather patterns so maybe our
programmers in San Francisco are just
renting out hoodies but insurance
workers in Chicago have to be a little
more formal when they go to work and
then check out everything that Seattle
they're just getting rained on their
raincoats and in Montana they're like
preparing for their like camping trip
and when we started running these
simulations we'd see that as you would
accumulate this inventory in the second
warehouse the shipments would continue
to go up and that's because the more you
have the higher the probability that
someone's order is going to be located
in that warehouse so you might have said
like well maybe you don't know need a
simulation to know this we just know
that we need to have enough inventory
there but the thing that really
complicates this for us is actually
seasonality so these are three different
pieces of clothing that we carry at Rent
the Runway
and kind of like demand indexes based on
the season season that we're in so
obviously in the summer this fleece
jacket is not something that people are
super interested in you don't really
want a fleece jacket when it's 100
degrees outside in the fall maybe
there's like some warm days and some
cold days so some people are interested
in this jacket but it's not like
gangbusters or anything like it's not
that popular but in winter it's like one
of the most popular SKUs and then kind
of the opposite is happening for this
orange sundress super popular in the
summer but absolutely no one wants this
in January so we could have assumed that
we keep accumulating inventory and
warehouse shipments it's going to
continue to go up but in reality what we
accumulated is mostly summer inventory
and now it's fall and no one wants
sundress right so the simulator was
really helpful for us impacted a lot of
decisions for our business a lot about
like when do we need to schedule manual
image dry transfers and just like kind
of fix the issues that happen when
you're only accumulating for customer
returns
it's a and in fact a lot of things
around labor planning because we need to
kind of know how many shipments are
coming out of the Texas warehouse so we
know how many people to hire and train
to work in that warehouse it impacts
buying strategies because there are some
things that we just don't have enough to
split between two warehouses we've got
to like make adjustments to those
strategies and then obviously Finance
wants to know what percentage of
shipments are going to be split
shipments where our shipping costs are
going to go up a lot the takeaways that
I have from this project is simply is
very simple it's not opinionated really
just gives you a clock and events and
kind of the framework of ech how to
develop your processes as Python
generators what's not not simple is your
logic you're really only billing a
simulation if you have like a very
complicated system to build this into a
thing that was like I didn't really
understand when I started this project
was simulations not optimization we're
not just like setting up system of
linear equations and then finding the
optimal solution your simulation is only
going to know the logic that you encode
into it and you can't just and it's only
gonna be able to test these strategies
that you want to test so you're gonna be
able to be able to use your simulation
to come up with a better answer but it's
not strictly an optimization kind of a
corollary to that is stakeholder
management people kind of might if
you're not like careful with your
stakeholders they're gonna think that
you're developing a magic 8-ball and
that you can like magically answer any
question that they have based on your
simulation but you're really building it
for like specific use cases so a thing
that came up a lot for us since they'd
be like oh well how is this gonna affect
churn and we're modeling out like how
the warehouse sends out shipments not
like how things are turning because
we're using historical data I would also
say that you should expect to spend the
majority of your time logging and
reporting so we wrote out two
dictionaries different event types we
would then save as JSON and s3 and then
make different reports of afterwards
using pandas and Seabourn and things
like that this is really like where the
vast majority of your work is gonna be
there
structure the state of well and
understand what things you should be
paying attention to in your simulation
and then the other thing I'm gonna say
you absolutely must build an acceptance
test build something there you know the
answer to and make sure that that is
working well because you're gonna get a
lot of requests about how to change your
simulation and you want to make sure
that you're not breaking anything this
is the team that worked on this project
Rob sakowski started it and then in sin
PI and then left and then vitaly and i
picked it up and in june when you were
getting close to launch we pulled in
danger kel to work with us on it he's
not a child he's an adult man he was a
child
black photo and then Jurgis our fearless
leader who helped a lot with our
stakeholder management these are kind of
interesting problems that you might be
interested in working on please come
talk to me afterwards and that's it I'm
ready to take questions hi thanks um
this isn't really a simple question but
more from like a business perspective so
you know halfway through your your
explanation I was thinking of you know
like the scooters or the bike share
things we're in the middle of the night
they send the vans around to move them
around from where they actually collect
probabilistically so has there been any
would it make any sense in your scenario
to have I don't know weekly flights that
between the two warehouses like
transport between what's missing from
one but is in the other or something
yeah that's what I'm doing right now
perfect intuition that's exactly what we
do it's like a little more complicated
than the bikes right because the bike is
a bike but like this gown is very
different from this sweatshirt and like
they're not fungible and they have very
different demands and that demand
depends on the season
thanks you talk about like where you
would use simple simulations versus
something like let's say a PI contracts
or a solver type of thing where you are
looking to optimize something
so I would say you want to use senpai
for simulations when you have something
that is you computationally either it's
too complicated to optimize or your
system is not well understood enough to
define it as a set of linear equations
like for us demand for each skew is
changing so rapidly it was hard for it's
hard for us to like coalesce that down
into a set of equations so I would say
optimization works well when you have
like a very well understood system that
you can like encode that way but a lot
of times the complexity is going to get
our hand very quickly yes so my question
was about the kind of error function
that you guys are trying to improve
against it seems like a very sort of
like complex problem and I guess I'm
wondering between iterations of your
simulation how do you know that your
simulation is actually doing a better
job at reducing cost or having a higher
fidelity model whatever that is right
and that's really hard because we didn't
have two warehouses so we started out by
just trying to simulate out what would
happen with one warehouse so we had like
all our historical orders and we're like
let's just run our warehouse starting at
a certain point in time and see if we
can replicate what actually happened
then we can't really compare to like
what what happened when there are two
warehouses because we haven't built it
yet but the function we're kind of like
trying to understand is like how do we
minimize the number of split shipments
that we have going out and the number of
Krosh and like understand like what
cross shipments are accumulating for us
but it's a good question because it was
it was really hard to actually come up
with like what our optimization function
was for this because initially we talked
to our stakeholders and they're like
okay we want to minimize split shipments
and maximize this and you're like okay
those two things are completely in
opposition to each other and cannot be
optimized optimized so a lot of this was
really kind of stimulating out what we
thought was going to happen rather than
and like trying to avoid like really big
missteps rather than coming up with like
an optimal solution
every now and then some celebrity wears
something and everybody has to have it
do you model that is you actually have
catastrophic events or is there enough
of that shirt that that's just more of
the same that there's always something
going on no we don't really model out
like when something is gonna like be
extremely popular like it if askew
becomes very popular what happens is
just goes to 100% utilization and then
we just don't have any more of them to
rent out and that's like probably the
biggest thing that I'm thinking about in
the future is how do we understand when
we have an item that's at a hundred
percent utilization how much more of it
should we have because you might be able
to say like oh I should have 10x this
maybe it's like not gonna be high in
demand next year because the trend is
gonna go away or like maybe I only
needed like a few more of this and if I
if I had 10x this like most of that
would go on underutilized so I think
that's that's a great question it's a
really hard problem for us because we
have you know tens of thousands SKUs
[Music]
where's that a feature everybody
attention logins they would purposely
only sell since only seven seven because
yeah I mean I think about that because
I've recognized basically every piece of
clothing so when I walk around New York
I can tell who's a customer and if there
is something about like oh I have
something that other people don't have
like my job as a data scientist is like
make sure everyone has what they want
yeah I think that's like an interesting
problem and it's not really solid with a
simulator like it's totally interesting
to think about we have time for one more
question
once you have your second warehouse up
and running how do you think about
integrating what the actual behavior is
into your simulation so we just finished
ramping our warehouses so now we have
like kind of two totally separate
systems so mostly we're thinking about
where to put the third one rather than
simulating out these two different
ecosystems more more we're thinking
about like what's someone over here
alluded to these like inventory
transfers on this weekly basis okay I
think we run off time and please give a
round of applause to your Megan
[Applause]